Traduttore: Maurizio Berti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Grazie a tutti.
È un piacere essere qui,
finalmente, a Cesena.
Io sono Matteo Cerri,
sono un ricercatore
dell'Università di Bologna
e oggi vi parlerò di ibernazione,
una cosa che sa sempre
un po' di fantascienza.
Infatti quando pensiamo
alla parola ibernazione
ci viene da guardare il cielo
e dire "Chissà dove si potrebbe andare..."
E l'ibernazione in effetti
è uno dei pilastri della fantascienza.
Qualcuno di voi riconoscerà
in queste foto quattro famosi film,
che non sarebbero potuti esistere
se non si fosse pensato all'ibernazione
come trucco cinematografico.
In realtà oggi non è più
così fantascienza.
Per esempio, questo è un articolo
del Guardian che ripropone l'ipotesi:
si può effettivamente ibernare un uomo?
Possiamo veramente viaggiare
nello spazio ibernando le persone?
Be', oggi la cosa ha preso
una piega un po' più decisa.
L'ESA, l'Agenzia Spaziale Europea,
un giorno mi ha telefonato,
il mio telefono squilla e mi dice:
"Buongiorno dr. Cerri, siamo dell'ESA,
vorremmo iniziare un gruppo di ricerca
che lavori su questo progetto
in previsione della missione su Marte
e anche altre. Cosa ne dice?"
"Mah, vengo volentieri!"
Infatti adesso faccio parte
di un gruppo di ricerca
e di consulenza per l'ESA,
che comprende molti colleghi
di tutto il mondo.
Esattamente lavoriamo
a cercare di sviluppare
una tecnologia che consenta
di ibernare gli astronauti.
In realtà l'origine di questa tecnologia
era pensata per la sanità,
ma ne parliamo
un pochino dopo nel dettaglio.
Intanto cos'è l'ibernazione?
È una parola che tutti conosciamo
gergalmente anche come letargo, a volte.
Quello che non sappiamo in realtà
è che l'ibernazione è uno stato complesso
Esiste l'estivazione,
l'ibernazione, il torpore.
Per semplificare, pensate
che l'ibernazione è una condizione
nella quale il nostro consumo di energia
si riduce fondamentalmente quasi a zero.
Esiste un animale,
che è lo scoiattolo artico,
la cui temperatura corporea
riesce a scendere addirittura sotto zero,
-2, -3 °C durante
la stagione dell'ibernazione.
Lo so, questi sono grafici:
gli scienziati usano grafici,
ce ne sono pochissimi di seguito
e vi guiderò attraverso la loro lettura.
Questo serve solo a farvi capire
che la capacità di raffreddarci,
noi in realtà ce la
portiamo dietro da molto tempo.
I nostri predecessori rettili,
che nella scala evolutiva
vengono proprio appena prima di noi,
in realtà non sono in grado di mantenere
la loro temperatura corporea costante,
per cui si raffreddano
quando l'ambiente è freddo,
e si riscaldano quando l'ambiente è caldo.
Se avete visto una lucertola d'estate,
si mette su una roccia,
aspetta che il sole la scaldi,
e quando è calda può iniziare
la sua vita, la sua attività.
Noi invece siamo in grado di mantenere
la nostra temperatura corporea costante.
Perché siamo in grado?
Perché molto tempo fa,
150 milioni di anni fa
o forse un po' di più,
il primo mammifero
che compare sulla Terra,
il proto-mammifero,
si trova di fronte
a un problema non indifferente:
la Terra, in quel periodo,
è popolata dai dinosauri.
E quindi non è facile
andare a prendere le ghiande,
mentre il T-rex ci passeggia sopra.
Quindi bisogna trovare un modo.
Come fare?
Be', un modo geniale sarebbe quello
di riuscire ad andare
a "fare la spesa" di notte,
quando non c'è il Sole,
perché i dinosauri di notte
sono più freddi,
perché non sono in grado
di generare il loro calore,
e noi invece sì.
È una strategia rischiosa.
Generare il proprio calore
costa molta energia.
È un trade off proprio
appena appena bilanciato:
ma funziona,
e quando i dinosauri
finalmente si estinguono,
i mammiferi iniziano
a popolare la Terra
e a dominarla in tutte
le nicchie ecologiche.
E l'ibernazione per molti di loro
diventa superflua.
Non ci son più predatori,
non è più necessario
questo tipo di risparmio.
La mantengono però gli animali che si
trovano in ambienti molto sfavorevoli.
Questa è una marmotta
delle Alpi, per esempio.
Cosa fa la marmotta
delle Alpi, quando iberna?
Fa questo tipo di cosa - oddio [direte],
un'altra figura, un altro grafico -
Be', ci sono molti dati
in questa figura, è una figura storica.
L'unica cosa che ritengo interessante
è questa cosa grigia,
che a un certo punto, vedete,
cade vicino all'asse dello zero.
Cosa vuol dire?
Quello è il consumo energetico
di quell'animale,
che improvvisamente
è in grado di crollare.
La marmotta autonomamente
è in grado attivamente
di spegnere il suo motore a un minimo
indispensabile per sopravvivere.
Questo sarebbe molto utile, in medicina.
Ci consentirebbe, per esempio,
di far sopravvivere con minor danni
le persone che hanno
un ictus cerebrale o un arresto cardiaco.
Il cervello, che consuma tantissimo,
improvvisamente potrebbe
smettere di consumare,
e quindi superare
il periodo critico senza danni.
Oggi non si può fare.
Si usa un pochino di raffreddamento,
ma si fa in maniera
poco diversa da questo:
col ghiaccio, con fluidi freddi.
E il nostro organismo
non vuole raffreddarsi.
Fra l'altro, che raffreddarsi fosse utile
l'avevamo capito molto tempo fa.
Durante la campagna
di Russia, per esempio,
i medici francesi avevano scoperto
una cosa interessante:
quando andavano a raccogliere
i feriti sul campo,
portavano gli ufficiali
nel quartiere degli ufficiali,
e i soldati nel quartiere dei soldati.
Quale era la differenza fra i due?
Gli ufficiali avevano
un quartiere riscaldato.
Si stava bene, perché erano ufficiali.
Purtroppo per loro,
gli ufficiali morivano come mosche,
e i soldati, che invece erano
acquartierati al freddo, sopravvivevano.
Per cui l'idea era che raffreddarsi
potesse far bene
in queste condizioni,
e fra l'altro i medici francesi
giungono a cambiare la definizione
di morte sul campo di battaglia.
La domanda che si fanno è:
ma il corpo è in decomposizione?
Se è in decomposizione,
allora la persona è morta.
Se no, quand'è che può essere morta?
Diciamo che se la testa
è lontana mezzo metro dal corpo,
allora la persona è morta.
In tutte le altre condizioni,
pensiamoci bene.
Poi ci sono altri esempi aneddotici.
Questa è la cittadina di Pskov, in Russia,
nella quale un anonimo scrittore
del British Medical Journal, nel 1900,
dice che la popolazione
- cito letteralmente -
"sleeps the winter off",
cioè passa via l'inverno dormendo,
riunendosi in una grande casa
nel centro del villaggio,
senza mangiare e aspettando la primavera.
Nessuno ha mai confermato
però questi findings.
Però ci sono esempi più recenti,
e sicuramente molto più monitorati.
Questa è la dottoressa Anna Bagenholm,
una collega, un medico anche lei norvegese
che è caduta in un fiordo gelato
facendo sci di fondo.
È rimasta un'ora sott'acqua.
È stata ripescata a una temperatura
corporea di 13,8 gradi centigradi.
È stata rianimata.
La dottoressa Anna sta benissimo,
e ha raccontato la sua esperienza
in alcuni articoli molto rilevanti.
Esiste quindi un modo
per sopravvivere a queste condizioni.
Esiste un modo che viene da lontano,
viene dal nostro
albero genealogico ancestrale,
e se vedete questi,
che sono tutti mammiferi,
e tutte le loro classi,
guardiamo questi punti colorati:
sono tutte le specie
che sono in grado di andare
in ibernazione, torpore, estivazione,
o qualunque capacità di sopprimere
la loro spesa energetica.
Sono distribuite in tutto l'arco.
Quindi il nostro antenato originale
era in grado di fare questa cosa,
e che anche noi, ragionevolmente,
saremmo in grado di farlo.
E infatti questo per esempio
è un paziente che arrivò
al Dipartimento di Neurologia
dell'Università di Bologna nel 2002
con una strana sindrome:
ogni tanto si sentiva stanchissimo,
e non riusciva a stare in piedi,
doveva sedersi, perdeva conoscenza.
Tutti gli esami erano negativi,
non si sapeva cosa avesse.
Fin quando un collega, molto astuto,
non registrò la sua temperatura
e scoprì che questo uomo
andava in una condizione
di torpore, ibernazione spontanea.
Sono molto rari,
sono stati descritti anche
altri casi però nel mondo.
Quindi sicuramente si può fare.
E come si può fare?
Be', quando ci mettiamo al freddo,
se ora foste uno di questi due modelli
avreste un freddo dell'anima,
e ovviamente il vostro corpo
farebbe brivido,
sarebbe non molto piacevole,
aumenterebbe la frequenza
cardiaca, la pressione.
E tutti questi organi si attiverebbero
per mantenere la vostra
temperatura corporea costante.
Quello che vogliamo fare,
e ciò che abbiamo fatto
per riuscire per la prima volta a mandare
in ibernazione un animale che non iberna,
è spegnere questo controllo,
spegnere il modo in cui il cervello
comanda questi organi,
dicendo a questi organi
di non funzionare più.
La regione del cervello
che controlla questi organi
è una regione molto piccola,
di una parte ancestrale
del nostro cervello.
Questa porzione si chiama Raphe Pallidus
- essendo tutti nomi di aree
cerebrali sono latini, di solito -
ed è qua evidenziato in fluorescenza,
ma adesso questi sono dettagli
solo scenografici.
Questo è il motore,
l'interruttore, l'accendino
che fa scaldare il nostro corpo
quando abbiamo bisogno di farlo,
e ci fa consumare energia.
Spegnerlo, ci fa risparmiare.
Infatti questo è un grosso ratto,
ripreso con una telecamera
agli infrarossi,
i colori più sono accesi
e più significa che sono caldi.
Questo è un animale normale
all'inizio del processo.
E dove l'hanno portato?
Qui non c'è più...
C'è ancora, si trova lì...
Però si è raffreddato così tanto,
che è praticamente
in equilibrio termico con l'ambiente.
Ha la stessa temperatura dell'ambiente,
che in questo caso era di 20 gradi.
Ma si può anche scendere
più in basso, ovviamente.
Perché questo ci potrebbe servire
per un viaggio spaziale?
La domanda non è banale.
Per andare su Marte
ci vogliono circa nove mesi,
più o meno, nelle condizioni ideali.
Si prende un'astronave,
diciamo che è previsto che abbia
sei membri dell'equipaggio,
chiusi in una scatolina,
una cabina telefonica volante.
Questi sei membri dell'equipaggio
mangeranno per il viaggio d'andata,
per il ritorno e per il periodo
che stanno su Marte.
E spedire qualcosa nello spazio
costa un sacco di soldi.
Si stima che il costo totale effettivo
sia quasi 60.000 euro al chilo.
Quando andate dal salumiere
a comperare il cibo
non lamentatevi se il prezzo
non è di questo tipo.
Di fronte a questa spesa
ci sono anche altri problemi:
nelle simulazioni fatte a Terra
molte persone vanno incontro
a una crisi psicotica.
Hanno quella che
si chiama Cabin Fever,
la fantascienza aveva già previsto tutto.
E inoltre ci sono delle radiazioni
molto pericolose, nello spazio:
fasci di protoni e ioni pesanti
che sono molto pericolosi
se ci si è esposti per molto tempo.
Risolvere questi problemi non è facile.
La cosa bellissima sarebbe
che se effettivamente
potessimo ibernare l'equipaggio,
l'equipaggio non deve più mangiare
- problema del cibo risolto-;
non può più avere attacchi psicotici,
non è cosciente - problema risolto -;
e per di più, come se la fortuna
non ci avesse aiutato abbastanza,
l'ibernazione conferisce un'importante
protezione dalle radiazioni.
Quindi sarebbe la condizione migliore
per il viaggio nello spazio.
E non solo per andare su Marte,
che tutto sommato è relativamente vicino,
ma già qualcuno inizia a pensare
ad andare qui, su questo piccolo pianeta,
che non è un pianeta ma è un satellite,
che è Europa,
che gira nell'orbita di Giove,
molto più lontano dei nove mesi di viaggio
che ci aspetterebbero per andare su Marte.
Detto questo,
qualcuno di voi potrà dirmi:
ma quanto costa fare queste cose?
Perché dobbiamo spendere per progetti
che chissà dove ci porteranno?
Ve lo dico io quanto costa:
non quanto costa questo,
ma quanto costa la scienza,
quanto costa questo tipo di approccio?
Questo è il costo
del Progetto Genoma Umano,
un costo tutto sommato importante,
che è accompagnato da costi rilevanti
di altri progetti scientifici,
per esempio l'Human Brain Project o l'LHC,
che ha scoperto il Bosone di Higgs.
Ma quanto costano le cose
della nostra vita di tutti i giorni?
Questo è quanto è costato
fare Avatar, il film.
Con un solo film avete finanziato
un progetto di scienza rivoluzionario.
Quanto beve la gente, secondo voi,
di alcolici negli Stati Uniti in un anno?
Beve così.
Fare una piccola tassazione di questo
potrebbe finanziare altri enormi progetti.
Ma ci sono anche cose ancora più costose:
quanto costa progettare
e sviluppare gli F35, per dire?
Un caccia militare.
Quindi la scienza non costa tanto.
Il suo costo è davvero modesto,
soprattutto rispetto
al vantaggio che può portare.
E perché possa portare questo vantaggio,
bisogna che la scienza
abbia una caratteristica
che accompagna
gli scienziati che ci lavorano:
la scienza deve essere libera,
libere devono essere
le persone che ci lavorano.
Questo cielo, che abbiamo visto
in tutte queste slide,
non lo abbiamo ancora visto,
non l'ha visto nessuno di noi.
Perché questo non è il cielo della Terra,
questo è il cielo visto da Marte.
E questo pallino qui è la Terra,
e qua si vede anche la Luna addirittura.
Allora, perché noi possiamo un giorno
effettivamente vedere questo cielo
bisogna che ricerche
come quella dell'ibernazione,
che è partita da curiosità scientifiche
e nessuno aveva pensato
a questa applicazione all'inizio,
è quella che si chiama ricerca di base,
nasce proprio dalla libertà
dello scienziato nel cercare,
nel perseguire quello
che lui ritiene sia interessante,
bisogna che la nostra libertà di ricerca
sia supportata ed appoggiata,
se vogliamo alla fine
aiutare e supportare la scienza.
Io vi ringrazio, siete stato
un pubblico bellissimo.
A presto.
(Applausi)